welcome to season two of the journey to
the micro cosmos and we are starting
things off with a pun very much intended
a bang or more accurately a multitude of
bangs and we should warn you it gets
weird there's poop
there's molted skin there's the
inexhaustible spirit of the tardigrade
in flagrante so how did we get here well
sex obviously if we're talking in the
grand biological scheme of things it is
for some an evolutionarily advantageous
way of making offspring but we're
talking about tardigrade sex right now
in part because of a pregnant water bear
that we started tracking in an episode
last season even though the mother-to-be
was completely motionless we were able
to see the heads of baby tardigrades
forming in the eggs and we were excited
to record and share the moment of all
those moss piglets hatching
unfortunately Nature had different plans
and we'll talk about that more in our
next episode but James our master of
microbes has been hard at work
documenting the lives of the tardigrades
in his care and that means not only have
we been able to find more tardigrades
hatching we've seen some particularly
vivid demonstrations of the steps that
came before these Hardy animals can
reproduce asexually via parthenogenesis
but our recent samples have been full of
frisky water bears and that is what
we're gonna focus on today
sure tardigrades contain an immense
capacity for survival it astounds and
boggles the mind and it is a joy and a
privilege to share the biology and
visual wonders of their lives alongside
all of the other
the organisms we talk about but
sometimes what the job asks for maybe
even demands is that we film nature as
it occurs this is not what James
expected when he ventured out to a river
to collect some mud even when it turned
out that he had hit a microbial jackpot
and counted at least fifteen tardigrades
on the first slide he prepared from the
sample but as he continued to watch he
saw these two smaller tardigrades both
mysteriously drawn to the underbelly of
a larger one they seemed to be trying to
reach into the belly with their piercing
mouths but the wise in the house in the
Hoos were all unclear their goal was
mysterious and besides tardigrades
rarely demonstrates such a focused
interest on much of anything but 20
minutes later those two Jabir's were
still at it
their determination became much more
understandable when the eggs inside the
bigger tardigrade became visible marking
her as a female holding a number of
unfertilized eggs and marking the
smaller tardigrades as males vying to do
the fertilization in a microscopic love
triangle or as we call it at the
macrocosmos headquarters a menage tois
degrade was that too much who knows so
just how focused are these male
tardigrades well remember that time we
watched a solitary tardigrade poop what
a nice surprisingly cute and relaxing
clip that was well now let's watch a
large female tardigrade defecate with
apparently no care at all for her
suitors and watch those two continue
poking the water bear anyway undaunted
by the cloud of poop around them
but even tardigrades surrender
eventually and after 30 minutes of this
poking and prodding one of the male's
made a graceful exit perhaps having lost
out on the mating battle with the path
clear the remaining male got a good hold
on the female's cuticle sticking with
her for a whole hour and their joint
endeavor to fertilize her eggs this
couple was not the only one we observed
in action in fact this sample was full
of tardigrades mating and the behavior
we observed was consistent which is
important scientifically given the
collective fascination with tardigrades
it might surprise you to learn that
their sex lives have not been well
documented perhaps the most thorough
study we were able to find is a 2016
paper that was conducted by scientists
at the snackin Berg Museum of Natural
History in gorlitz Germany it was
published in the zoological Journal of
the Linnaean Society and their work
chronicles the mating behavior of ice
ohit's abayas bastok i a different
species from the one we're observing
here but their work was still a helpful
basis from which to understand the
various oddities and necessities of
water bear sex the adulthood of
tardigrades is often defined by the
number of molt's it takes for them to
reach sexual maturity for example the
female ID astok eye develops eggs during
her third molt but at this stage the
female doesn't shed off their molted
outside called the exo via they molt
their cuticle but then they stay in it
like wearing your shed skin like a coat
and why not they stay in there along
with their eggs when male tardigrades
were added to the mix they made a
beeline for these egg bearing females in
the exact technical terms used by the
scientists in the paper the process
starts with the male quote bringing his
cloaca close to the mouth opening in the
Exodia and thus begin
process of quote mutual stimulation the
female uses her stylet sand sucking
pharynx to prod at the male's abdomen as
part of a mating process that will take
similar to our tardigrades about an hour
it all ends of course with ejaculation
but how that fertilization occurs can
vary in some species sperm might enter
through an opening in the Exodia and
others the male Knight used their stylus
to poke holes in the shed cuticle that
they then deposit their sperm into one
species has been seen using both of
those methods the observations that have
been documented are that challenging
combination of rare and different where
it's not clear how everything fits
together and in cases like the species
we're looking at right now that means
the mechanisms actually remain unclear
the sexual habits of this species are
undocumented this is science
right here you're watching it as for
when and how the sperm is deposited
either we weren't able to film the exact
right moment or it happened so subtly
that we missed it in short it's
different for different species and it's
not well studied and even though we had
a slide full of frisky tardigrades it
was still a challenge to observe
sometimes here at journey to the micro
cosmos we end our episodes talking about
how observing the micro cosmos
gives us new and better perspectives on
their whole rest of the world but
sometimes we're just excited to have the
opportunity to see something so few
people have seen and that's just
interesting because it is and hopefully
this video will be part of a hopefully
ongoing tradition to record tardigrade
mating and next week we're gonna be back
with the fruits of their labor to show
you the highs and the lows of tardigrade
birth
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us journey to the micro
cosmos is produced by complexly if you
want to keep imagining the world
complexly with us
check out the crash course business
entrepreneurship learning playlist
hosted by Anna Akana
over 17 episodes she'll explore how to
take an idea and grow it into a thriving
business the first video can help you
figure out if you want to be or already
are an entrepreneur the link for the
playlist is in the description also
thank you so much to all of our patrons
on patreon for helping us be able to
spend so much time researching and
filming and observing these little
beauties we could not do it without you
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us you can go ahead and
use your stylus and sucking pharynx to
prod at that subscribe button